lorraine here with darren gone from
comic cave studios welcome to the
Guardians premiere and there's a
beautiful display behind us of qubits
can you tell us a little bit about what
they are so it's basically we've been
you know strategically aligned with the
distant Marvel but the green Marvel and
we've been doing the last two or three
hundred carpets with them and is the
third actually so we're going to do the
fourth and fifth as well these are
specifically designed creatively
engineered with Marvel for the red
carpet and we've tried to show like
diversity from high-end collectibles all
the way to like creative collectibles
like this and this one we come up with
cubits very cool now in our previous red
carpets this is a purple carpet of
course but in her previous red carpets
we've seen a lot of really detailed
statues you guys do some really like
almost sort of photorealism in in mini
figure what was the idea behind creating
these qubits which are very cute and
collectible and stackable like I said we
wanted to be more diverse so on the
first red carpet we showed something
really high-end and then we kind of
skewed towards something more affordable
and this is really for the mass market
so these are really stuff they want to
put everywhere for everyone to enjoy
wonderful what I'm enjoying it and
you're about to enjoy the film what
Guardian are you most excited to see
tonight I am always a good guy a group
guy more baby Groot you guys thank you
so much for sponsoring in the live
stream today and let's check in on the
purple carpet just down the way